as you know our show is dedicated to
covering the biggest news of the week
whatever that news may be we have a long
proud one-week history of doing that so
what was the biggest news story of this
week we begin in Oklahoma tonight with
an execution that didn't go as planned
a convicted killer from Oklahoma dies
after a botched execution
okay okay okay I know what you're
thinking you're thinking white you know
you're not gonna really do a comic take
on the death penalty right it's your
second episode I haven't even decided if
I like this show yet
well you're right don't change the
channel we don't have to talk about the
death penalty no one is forcing us to in
the application of the death penalty in
this country we have seen significant
problems I think we do have to as a
society ask ourselves some some
difficult and profound questions do we
do we really have to do that can you not
just answer those question for us
because I do not want to talk about the
death penalty and judging by the noise
that you make when you talk about it
neither do you what happened in Oklahoma
is deeply troubling
I know that sound that's the sound of a
man drowning on dry land desperately
hoping for Biden to suddenly walk out
into the gopro's garden in an open road
oh god John Oh Jose here thank god
you're here ah let's lighten the mood
everyone let's talk about Benghazi okay
okay so let's do this then let's talk
about the death penalty and before you
turn this show off there was a YouTube
video this week of tiny hamsters eating
tiny burrito it's as magical and as
uncomplicated as you think and if you
make it to the end of this story I
promise we will watch it together okay
so you have to stay with us you have to
stay with us to get it okay so the death
penalty should it exist and what should
its limits be can someone give me a
broad almost infantile guideline of when
they think it's appropriate the Supreme
Court has already told us that the death
penalty is constitutional I will do
believe in the death penalty but but
only with respect to those who are
guilty of committing the crime okay
bones idea
we shouldn't execute innocent people I
think most people would probably agree
with that you sir are a regular Atticus
Finch but but executing the innocent is
not really the tough question here is
whether we should be executing the
guilty and let me acknowledge right up
front that I come to this as a bit of an
outsider Britain does not have capital
punishment so in a way I really don't
know what I'm talking about
but in another way I really do know what
I'm talking about because before 1965 we
didn't just have capital punishment we
literally went medieval on people's
asses the history of capital punishment
in Britain is a long and bloody one
since the Middle Ages laws condemned to
death have variously faced the
boiled alive burnt at the stake or hung
drawn and quartered yeah we did that we
boils people and in the grand tradition
of British cuisine if anything we over
boiled them we boil them up
we we loved killing people so much we
kept coming up with new inventive
techniques that look like they were
designed by the marquis de sade and
named by willy wonka this is the head
crusher the small and seemingly
innocuous thumb biter originates in 14th
century Scotland these devices have
almost childlike names like penny
Winkies that's right
penny wink is a delightful English
cousin of the throaty tugtug and the
jolly shocky buzz-buzz tickly wickley
since I know I know that all of this is
still technically horrifying but that's
kind of the point because whether you
are boiling people alive or putting them
to sleep with a tiny injection
administered by a puppy dressed as
Winnie the Pooh in the end you are
getting the same result and here's the
thing just because the British people
don't have the death penalty anymore
doesn't mean that we don't want it back
recent polls suggest that at least half
the population would choose to have it
reinstated which makes complete sense
because the death penalty is one of
those things that is natural to want but
you shouldn't necessarily have the death
penalty is like the McRib when when you
can't have it it's so tantalizing but as
soon as they bring it back you think
this is epically wrong should this be
allowed in a civilised society and by
the way there is your new slogan Magrib
you are welcome you are welcome you can
have that for free that's yours
because because there are things about
having the death penalty which might
make you a little bit queasy what does
the United States have in common with
Iran Iraq and Saudi Arabia the answer is
the death penalty according to Amnesty
International those four nations and
China are responsible for 82 percent of
the world's executions look this is
gonna seem like a gross simplification
but any list that contains Iran Iraq
Saudi Arabia and China is not a list you
want to be on ideally you want to be on
one of those lists that Finland is on
Finland Finland is on all the good lists
like countries with the best pastries or
best countries to host your overseas
lesbian wedding and I know I know what
some of you are thinking but John I hear
you saying that most Western countries
no longer have executions but if someone
committed a heinous crime I would still
very much like to kill them okay well
let's start with if there have been 312
DNA exonerations in this country since
we've been doing forensic testing one
life in parole how things which were
once considered complete airtight
evidence against somebody are now sort
of being viewed as junk shut science
isn't it interesting is interesting
really the word that you're looking for
there Cooper facts found on Snapple caps
are interesting that the Statue of
Liberty's nose is four feet six inches
long hot that's an interesting fact
but facts like innocent people are
potentially executed by our government
on a regular basis and not so much
interesting as horrifying put it
this way if you found that on the bottom
of a Chobani lid that would like I can
tell you of Chobani even harder to
swallow than it already is and look look
statistics suggest that false
convictions aren't all that rare I this
week we are learning from the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences a study that shows four percent
of death row inmates are innocent
I think you might be using the wrong
tone 4%
well the outrage about this must be off
the charts I remember a certain Texas
governor who felt that for individual
cases of voter impersonation in the last
decade was a moral issue important to
address thank any person who does not
want to see fraud believes in having
good open honest elections transparent
well we take it to the Supreme Court to
the Supreme Court over a voter
impersonation rate essentially close to
zero percent so a potential executing
the innocent rate of 4% must really eat
away at Rick Perry your state has
executed 234 death row inmates more than
any other governor in modern times have
you have you struggled to sleep at night
with the idea that any one of those
might have been innocent no sir I've
never struggled with that at all nope I
never struggled with it in fact I sleep
great like a big muscular baby 14 hours
or not legs in the air with a mobile
above my head crying when I myself
I'm a big baby I sleep like a baby but
ok ok let's imagine for a moment a
magical world where you could be sure of
someone's guilt what are the arguments
for killing them then is it that it's a
deterrent to others there is no credible
evidence that the death penalty is a
particular deterrent to violent crime
although to be fair the death penalty is
an amazing deterrent to fishing without
a license
listen Todd I'd love to go with you but
is it worth it you've got a wife and
children so what about the argument then
that we shouldn't have to pay to house
and feed a convicted killer an average
death penalty case
cost the state millions of dollars in
California alone since 1978 the total
cost of enforcing the death penalty has
been over four billion dollars that's
308 million dollars for each of the 13
executions carried out in fact it costs
up to 10 times more to give someone the
death penalty than life in prison so
what a death sentence is really saying
is hey this is America and the way we
treat the most despicable members of our
society is by spending the entire budget
of the Lord of the Rings trilogy on them
so what what we know now is the death
penalty is expensive potentially kills
innocent people and doesn't deter crime
and here is where it gets hard harder
than is potentially appropriate for a
comedy show late on a Sunday night but
if we are going to answer difficult and
profound questions as the president told
us to the toughest one is probably if
someone is guilty of committing a
horrible crime and the family of the
victim want the perpetrator executed do
we want to live in the kind of country
that gives that to them I would say no
you might very reasonably say yes or at
the very least
but
but it's a question that is going to
need an answer and in the meantime a
much easier question is do you want to
watch a YouTube video of a tiny hamster
eating a tiny burrito it's at this point
at this point you have earned it
and that is how you end a comprehensive
segment on the death penalty